It’s the year 478 BCE.
And an interesting embassy of various diplomats
presents itself to the Athenian Assembly.
This video is sponsored by the Great Courses
Plus but more on that later.
This embassy that presented itself before
the Athenian Assembly, well actually they
would first come before the Prytaneis who
where part of the Boule who would decide whether
to present them before the Assembly but the
Athenian government is all but not simple
so for simplicity sake let's just say the
embassy presented itself before the Assembly.
This embassy was a coalition of various Greek
Ionian city states, but also most likely other
Greek city states were part of it as well.
And they all came to Athens, to present before
the Athenians, their plea for Athens to take
the leadership of the Hellenic Alliance away
from the Spartans.
Why is there a Hellenic Alliance, why are
the Spartans leading it, why are the Aionians
asking Athens to help, and how is this all
even related to the creation of the Athenian
Empire?
Well let's get into it.
…
Before 478 the Hellenic world was embroiled
in a conflict the scale of which they have
never seen before.
The Persian Empire ruling over most of the
eastern known world had set it sights on Greece,
and so the conflict known as the Greco-Persian
Wars started, I do not intend to cover this
entire topic as that would require an entire
video series of its own but it is important
to mention certain events from it that lead
to the arrival of the aforementioned diplomatic
embassy to Athens in 478.
So the simplified version goes like this.
The Greco Persian Wars started with a rebellion
of Ionian Greeks against the Persian rule
in 499.
They were supported in this rebellion by Athenians
and Eretrians.
The revolt was subdued by the Persians in
493 but the Persian king Darius vowed to make
Athens and Eretria pay for their support of
the revolt.
And so with this in mind he invaded Greece
in 490 where he was promptly defeated at Marathon
by mainly Athenian but also some Eretrain
forces led by Callimachus.
During the battle Callimachus was supported
by 10 strategoi, basically Athenian Generals.
The most important of which were Aristides,
Themistocles, Xanthipus and, of course Miltiades.
Militiades was the one to pressure the Athenians
to face the Persians in open battle and he
was the one who devised the battle tactic
that defeated the Persians even though they
outnumbered the Athenians.
After the battle the story goes that the remaining
Persians wanted to use their fleet to attack
Athens since the Athenian army was in Marathon.
But the Athenians marched as fast as they
could in full armour, 40 km from Marathon
to Athens, just in time to see the Persian
fleet arriving, who upon seeing the Athenian
army in the city, decided to retreat.
This story was later romanticized, and confused
with a different story, resulting in the story
we know today.
Which is that after the Athenian victory at
Marathon a herald called Philippides was dispatched
to announce the news in Athens.
He ran the full 40 km in armour exclaimed
before the Assembly “We've won!” and promptly
died of exhaustion.
This story is why today’s marathon is called
a Marathon and why it is 40 km long, well
not exactly, but I digress.
After the Persian defeat at Marathon a year
later Miltiades led the Athenian troops on
the offensive but this proved to be not so
successful and he even managed to get grievously
injured during this campaign.
His rivals in Athens used this failed campaign,
and other arguments, to get Miltiades imprisoned.
This man who helped Athens defeat the Persians
at Marathon died due to his injuries while
being imprisoned by said Athenians.
He was also almost ostracized if he had lived
a couple of years longer to see this new law
come into practice.
What is Ostracism?
Well for those who don’t know ostracism
was an Athenian way of getting rid of people
who might be aspiring to overthrow the democracy.
If more than 6000 votes were casted, who's
ever name was mentioned the most in those
6000+ votes was exiled from Athens for a period
of 10 years.
The problem with this was that even though
the reason why the ostracism was introduced
was quite altruistic, it just ended up being
yet another way of getting rid of your political
rivals and almost anyone who became popular
in Athenian politics got ostracized eventually.
Even the person who introduced ostracism and
reformed Athenian democracy to be more “democractic”,
Cleisthenes, is said to have been ostracized
himself, maybe the sources are unclear, but
it is known that his son was later ostracised.
So a little foreshadowing there of how it
ends for most of the people in these videos.
Going back to the Greco-Persian Wars, Darius
was preparing another invasion of Greece but
died in 486 and was succeeded by his son Xerxes.
Xerxes had to deal with rebellions and consolidate
his power within Persia and due to this he
put his father’s planned Greek invasion
on hold until 480.
During this 10 year interbellum in the war,
two prominent politicians came to ascendents
in Athens.
The veterans of the Battle at Marathon Themistocles
and Aristides.
Themistocles was popular with the lower classes
mainly because he came from them, he was known
as a cunning man who always had a plan and
to whom sometimes the ends did justify the
means.
Aristides on the other hand positioned himself
against Themistocles, he was the champion
of the upper classes, called “The just Aristides”
by his supporters, he was incorruptible, conservative
and as Plutarch puts it, he was in politics
“to secure the best results consistent with
safety and righteousness” not to be a populist.
Nonetheless the main issue these two disagreed
on was whether Athens should focus more on
its navy or its military, with Themistocles
supporting the former and Aristides the latter.
This heated debate culminated in 483 when
a very rich seam of silver was found in the
Athenian controlled mines Laurion.
Themistocles wanted to use the new found money
to build a great new navy for Athens, while
Aristidis fearing this would mean Athen’s
abandonment of its military in favor of the
navy proposed dividing up the money amongst
the Athenian citizens.
At the end it looked like a compromise was
going to be reached between the two sides
but an ostracism was held in this time.
During the ostracism an illiterate man came
up to Aristides not recognizing him.
He asked Aristides if he could please write
the name Aristides on his pottery shard (which
was the ballot), confused Aristides asked
the man “has Aristides wronged you at any
point” to which the man replied “No, and
I do not even know him, but it irritates me
to hear him everywhere called 'the Just”.
Aristides than true to his nickname wrote
his own name on the pottery shard.
Unsurprisingly Aristides was ostracized, meaning
Themistoclese won and Athens promptly started
to build one of the largest fleets in the
Aegean.
In 481, Greeks learned of the planned Persian
invasion and so called for a Greek Council.
There were around 700 Greek city states at
the time but only 70 showed up to the council.
However even with that it has to be stated
how big of a deal this is, even 10% of the
Greek city states showing up to a council
when some of them are technically in an active
war with each other is impressive.
The council decided a Hellenic Alliance with
the power to levy troops and send ambassadors
would be formed to fight the Persians.
This Hellenic Alliance promptly made the Spartans
the main leaders of the alliance and of the
joined military, because I mean it's the war
obsessed Spartans who else should lead the
allies to war.
The Athenians, on the other hand with their
fancy new big navy, and due to some clever
diplomatic maneuvering by Themistocles, managed
to be appointed as the leaders of the Allied
navy.
And so with Athenian Themistocles leading
the Navy and
Spartan Leonidas the military
what follows next are the stories of legends.
Persians win at Thermopylae killing Leonidas
and march to Attica to burn down Athens along
with a bunch of other cities and temples along
the way.
Most Athenians however retreated with the
Hellenic Alliance to the Isthmus of Corinth
so they were safe for now.
Also Athens during this time passed a law
of recalling exiles, meaning Aristides could
return and so he did, promptly serving under
Themistocles in the Allied Navy.
Also since Leonidas was dead he was promptly
succeeded in the leadership of the allies
by another spartan Pausanias.
The Persian navy was then defeated thanks
to Themistocles cunning at the Battle of Salamis.
After that the allies went on the offencive
defeating the invading forces at the Battle
of Plataea and the remaining Persian Navy
at the Battle of Mycale.
During the Battle of Platea Aristidis showed
his confidence, orator skills, and honor,
even helping to put down a conspiracy within
the army.
These actions gave the allies great admiration
for Aristides but more on that later.
With the Persian threat no longer imminent
Athenians returned to their burned downed
and destroyed city.
Athenians started to rebuild their city along
with the destroyed walls, naturally the Spartans
objected to the Athenians rebuilding their
walls because well they didn’t want their
main rivals to have walls.
Themistocles however, ever the trickster,
devised a plan of how to trick the Spartans.
He told the Athenians to focus on only building
the walls as quick as they can.
He then headed an embassy to Sparta along
with a man named Kimon where he delayed for
as long as he could.
Spartans however didn’t believe his words
and so Themistocles suggested the Spartans
send envoys of their own, to see for themselves
if Athenians are building the walls or not.
He then himself send a herald to Athens, telling
them to keep hostage the Spartan envoys that
will arrive.
The Athenians did so and when Aristides arrived
to Sparta to enform Themistocles that the
walls have been finished, enraged Spartans
wanted to imprison the entire Athenian embassy
to which Themistocles nicely pointed out they
had the Spartan envoys in custody in Athens.
So the Spartans reluctantly released the Athenian
Embassy and the Athenians released the Spartan
embassy.
Before leaving, Themistocles informed the
Spartans for future reference that Athenians
weren’t just any Greek city the Spartans
could boss around and in fact it was a city
of distinguished people which could make their
own decisions without Spartan or any other
city’s consent.
The new Athenian Walls on top of encompassing
a much larger area than the actual city itself
where also build around the new Athenian port
Piraeus.
Themistocles couldn’t stress enough how
valuable having access to the sea was for
the Athenians now that they were the dominant
naval power in the Greek world.
He even suggested that if worse comes to worse,
the Athenians abandoned their city in favor
of defending Piraeus.
Whether that will ever happen, I guess we’ll
just have to see.
Going back to the Greco Persian Wars the Hellenic
Alliance continued being on the offensive
taking over Gallipoli, raiding Cyprus and
capturing Byzantium.
All while most of the Ionian Greeks, remember
them, rebelled from the Persians and joined
the Alliance as well.
However, during this entire time, the Spartans
where the ones in charge of the alliances
actions.
After all as mentioned before you’re going
to war with the largest Empire in the known
world, so you probably want to make the war
obsessed Spartans the leaders of the Alliance.
But now that the imminent threat of Persian
invasion of Greece has been largely stifled,
the problems of Spartan hegemony are starting
to come to light.
The Spartan leader of the alliance Pausanias
was said to be dictatorial, violent, corrupt
and even often irrational.
Now these statements may have been just Athenian
propaganda at play but considering that Spartans
were known for carrying sticks and beating
with them anyone who disagreed with their
opinion, it would be easy to assume that Pausanias
wasn’t really liked by the allied troops.
Which brings us back to 478 and the allied
embassy coming to Athens, pleading for them
to take over the leadership of the Alliance.
Athenians agreed to take the leadership away
from the Spartans under certain conditions.
The exact details of this and how the new
alliance was runned is a matter of debate
because no sources talk about it in detail,
but to present a coherent story I am going
to go with N.G.L.
Hammonds representation.
Each ally will swear an oath to the gods to
have an offencive and a defensive alliance
with Athens. (also sometimes to the alliance
itself as a whole, depends)
They will also be required to participate
in the alliance’s council on the island
of Delos.
Each ally has a seat and one vote on the council,
however the Athenian vote is equivalent to
the whole alliances council vote.
Plus Athens will hold a permanent Hegemony
over the leadership of the alliance’s navy
and army.
On top of that any booty gotten from raiding
and pillaging the Persian territory will be
divided amongst the allies and of course 1/10
of it will go to the gods.
Lastly each alli has to either support the
alliance in military/naval aid or financial
payments which would be held at a treasury
in Delos.
Why Delos you ask?
Well partly because it’s conveniently placed
in the middle of the Aegean, partly because
it’s an island, and so easily defendable
by the Athenian Navy, and partly because it
is a very religiously important site in the
Hellenic world.
It is the island where the twin gods of Apollo
and Artemis were born and came down from the
mountain Cynthus.
Having the allies meet at such a religious
important place would make them think twice
before breaking the oath they swore to Athens
before the gods.
Most allies mainly the islanders and the Ionians
agreed to these terms while others like Sparta
just left the alliance.
Why Sparta gave up the hegemony of the Alliance
is uncertain but it is mostly agreed that
they felt like the Persians have been soundly
defeated and there was no longer a reason
to continue on with the Alliance.
This combined with the Athenian restructuring
of the alliance meant that not everybody was
happy being part of the alliance anymore.
Why did other allies agree to the terms set
by Athens?
Well for the Aioninas and some islanders this
was a perfect deal as they were in a constant
threat from Persia and so being part of such
an alliance with one of the most powerful
cities in the Greek world meant protection.
Other cities even at this early point may
have been strongarmed by Athens in to joining
the new alliance but we have no way of knowing
that for sure.
Lastly there’s an economic aspect to it.
Being part of the alliance means protection,
stability and more streamlined access to markets,
something which the trade oriented Thassos
would enjoy.
So in 478 the Athenians became the leaders
of a newly created alliance which henceforth
we shall call the Delian league, a political
entity which gradually over the course of
the 5th century became the Athenian Empire.
So now that Athens is leading this new Delian
League what are they going to do about the
Persian threat, also what is Themistocles
and Aristides role in this new league, plus
who was that new guy named Kimon who helped
Themistocles trick the Spartans?
All very good questions that are going to
be answered in the next video of my Athenian
Empire Series.
However if you can’t wait for that video
because let's be honest ‘I’ don’t even
know when the next video in this series is
going to come out, you can always go to the
Great Courses Plus and go on a deep dive of
Athenian history.
For example If you want to learn how that
complicated democratic government of Athens
actually worked, bam, a series by an actual
History Professor all about Athenian democracy.
It’s so detailed ... it's great.
And you don’t have to stick to just classical
history because ou my god there’s so many
videos on so many historical topics on the
Great Courses plus not to even mention all
the none history videos.
For example, as an amature musition myself,
I found this lecture on how playing music
affects your brain very fascinating, I highly
recommend it.
So if you want to get a free trial to learn
some new things go to thegreatcoursesplus.com/MLaserHistory
or click the link right in the description.